[Music]
let's talk about stepping into colombian
music i read that you said
that the rhythms were familiar to you
but that the instrumentation and
orchestration was different so what
exactly does that mean to those of us
that aren't songwriters and how is this
a different experience than making music
for moana or in the heights yeah i found
that immersing myself in colombian music
it was a lot like going through your
cousin's
family picture album like oh i see how
we're similar and i see how we're
different that's generally the story of
of music in latin america which you know
traverses its borders and and we share
so much again
the the the task is full immersion and
full research and you know you would
swap out our puerto rican cuatro for a
colombian teaple um to write um songs uh
that are really accordion-centric um
that was really exciting to give you
know our main character mirabelle
doesn't have a gift or a superpower but
she plays the crap out of an accordion
while she sings and so that was really
joyous um to write a a song for her that
is it was really inspired by a style of
music in colombia called bambuco that's
in 3 4 time there's not a lot of disney
tunes in 3 4 time and
and finding that was really exciting so
it's it's sort of these little things
here and there and then colombian
musicians like all the way down the line
to really give it that authenticity but
but the harder part and the more
rewarding part for me is really just
finding what these characters want and
what they yearn for and how they feel
about each other and finding their
pulses and rhythms and and what that
sounds like when they're talking to each
other and lynn you've been working on
this for five years so as a recovering
perfectionist
how do you know when a song is done
uh when disney says we've sent it off to
master it's done um but i could keep
fiddling for forever i know i have the
best beta testers in the world in my
house because i have a six-year-old and
a three-year-old and if they like it i'm
good and they are not shy about their
opinions i also married to a woman who
doesn't really like musicals that much
so i've got the toughest bar to clear in
my house
there's a song in this movie called dos
orogitas
it i
it's a heartbreaker of a tune
my very cool cucumber wife was in tears
and she went that's the best song you've
ever written and i said okay
we're done here
um i can't even talk about that without
crying um but that's you know if i've if
i've made my family happy then i've
clearly i'm good um they're a really
good test audience oh lynn that was so
beautiful and i can attest that i that
song
when i watched it everybody was just so
emotional and
you put so much attention to detail in
your music and i almost feel like that's
your superpower and gift i was talking
to stephanie and she was saying how you
explained to her that one of maribel's
songs was kind of like the waltz because
the waltz feels out of time kind of like
how maribel is out of time with her
family and i'm like man if people just
knew how much lynne puts into this and
she didn't even know that
what would you say because you mentioned
your family and beta testing with them
what is your superpower and gift in your
family and and like maribel's mom did
you eat a meal growing up that healed
you or gave you life i think any
writer's greatest tool is
in their toolbox is empathy i i think
that's the gay like i don't know any
other way to write other than to put
myself in the character
feel what they're feeling
talk to myself till it feels true and
write it down like that's and whether
it's at a keyboard or at a piano like
that's the job uh and it's that simple
and it's that uh complicated and
the joy with my family is they
they are so used to it like they just
see daddy talking to himself or crying
in the corner and they go daddy's
writing it's fine um and and that's been
really wonderful because i think they
also understand that empathy and seeing
how someone else feels is a superpower
um and is and and is half the battle
when it comes to living in this world um
when it comes to uh home cooking my mom
wasn't much of a cook but like once a
year she would make like two
big old pots of like her tomato sauce
and it lived in freezers and we lived
off that for the rest of the year
so my mom's tomato sauce is probably the
one for us you know i love siempre luis
and and your father i love the
connection that you guys have because i
feel that kinship with my dad
what power do you think you know your
dad gives you
well he was really along for the ride on
all of this like he came to colombia
with us and
um it was sort of it was really nice
to have him along on the journey because
he had insights that i wouldn't have had
having grown up in puerto rico that i
wouldn't necessarily have been able to
contribute he he i remember him telling
us the story of his grandmother my
great-grandmother and how she ran the
house there were 12 kids and everyone
who married into the family gave their
paychecks to her which she re-allotted
accordingly according to to need and i
think ended up being a big inspiration
for the character of alma and the way
alma runs that madrigal household so my
dad was really along for the ride for
this i think
as selfishly it was nice for him to see
how hard i worked and how tricky it is
to write these tunes you know he wanted
me to be a lawyer and here we are
writing disney tunes so uh it worked out
pretty nicely but it was it was actually
really nice for him to sort of see the
process from beginning to end on this
wow that's really cool that he's
alongside i love how you guys work
together and you always pull from him it
it means so much to me to hear you say
that how do you unlock your inner child
and how do you tap into little and
and and create from that space when
you're working for disney
yeah i i don't think little lynn has
ever relinquished the keys
i don't think he's ever given me the
keys to to be an adult i i'm always
thinking about
what would have blown my mind when i
because i'm here talking to you because
i saw under the sea when i was nine
years old and it exploded my brain and
i'm still trying to put the pieces back
together
the feeling of weightlessness
seeing that number
is something that has never really gone
away
one of the best parts of adulthood
is
is getting to do the things maybe
younger you didn't get to do the
pandemic version of that for me was i
just like started buying sugary cereals
i was like i wasn't allowed to have
lucky charms i'm buying lucky charms i'm
buying cinnamon toast crunch i'm a
grown-up and we're in a pandemic and i'm
eating this
um and so i mean that's like a very
surface version of satisfying the inner
child but when you're creating
your own your first audience is you and
and and that voice is very much present
in me when i'm when i'm particularly
when i'm writing for disney
delivery
i gave you the special since you're the
only madrigal kid with no gift i call it
the not special special since uh
you have no gift
uh thanks
john and stephanie i left this film
wanting to see so much more of your
characters together so good that's
better than the opposite that's great
if and when there is a spin-off i hope
you guys are down oh yeah no doubt
of course as someone that comes from a
huge family it was so beautiful for me
to see disney bring this magical massive
extended family of the madrigals to life
and when you come from one you know that
each family member really does bring a
specific gift to the table based on the
role they play
so i wanted to know what super powers or
gifts would you possess in your family
and what are some of the ones that they
would possess i mean the one i do
possess with my family is i'm like the
peacemaker because like when stuff
starts getting uh
i'm able to sort of go like that's a
really good point why don't we take a
walk around the outside of the house and
look at some of the street you know it's
like i'm very
like cool i'm very much the person that
sort of tries to deflect
the
hubbub or like the craziness that starts
to go oh my god i'm the opposite really
you're the instigator
i'm the one that starts all the trouble
in the household otherwise it starts
everybody at each other and yeah yeah
because i like i like
tumultuousness i like conflict i like i
love that that's funny you know we all
have we all bring different things to
your family something different and
that's what the movie
what's also interesting in this film is
that some of the characters get their
gifts at the age of five and the reason
why i found that interesting is because
i think at a very young age in real life
sometimes we can get pigeonholed by our
families into a certain career path you
know by five you're a musician or you're
an athlete
so i'm curious what did you both want to
be when you grew up and was that based
on a family expectation starting with
you john i really fought against all
family expectations they wanted me to be
in business or or something
standard and i said nah i'm gonna be a
comedian actor and they were like we
didn't come to this country for you to
be worse than us
and i was like what that's not the the
expectation i expected from them so i
went against all that and i said i'm
going to be an actor regardless if i
have success or not i didn't care and
here we are today i don't think i really
decided what i wanted to be until i was
a teenager and then i saw
john on tv for the first time in one of
his one-man shows doing a monologue
about
when he decided to become an actor which
is when he saw a chorus line on broadway
and
hearing him say these words and have
these like revelation that he could also
do that made me in turn also have the
revelation as i was like watching tv in
my little bedroom in houston texas
watching this person who had a broadway
show talking about another broadway show
you know it was like all these different
levels of oh i could do i could do that
then i could do that i could be an actor
i could be an actor maybe i could be an
actor you know and now you're doing it
now i'm doing it with mirabelle you're
giving little girls a chance to go look
at me i can do it too it's beautiful
it's very cool it's like very very
the way that things kind of trickle down
and the things that hit you and the
things that sort of what's the word when
something like gives you permission or
uh yeah or like really like imprinted on
you when something imprints on you when
you're that young and you're told like
the possibilities are there for you like
it's very very very exciting because the
world opens up to you and important how
important this movie is yeah and how
surreal is that that now you guys are
working together it's crazy oh yeah it's
amazing it's amazing
bananas when i heard the john was in the
cast i was like
what's the for real like i lost my mind
and i ran to see her in the heights and
she crushed it in the heights thank you
that's so funny i'm dominican so step
everything you did with in the height
and also what is it about a chorus line
because that was like also very personal
to me too maybe it was maria in the in a
chorus line that was just like oh latinx
we can do this yes lopez lopez
it was also that like we had so little
so we were looking for the one anything
right and so when you see it you attach
to it immediately because you're not you
know john's talked a lot about
how much the what was the stat that you
gave about the census so it was oh yeah
we're 20 we're almost 20 of the census
and yet four percent now is better
because last year was three percent of
the faces in front of the camera that's
not okay i've always loved jonah you've
been so outspoken about that and that's
why it means so much that you guys are
bringing this story to life you know
i think we just bought up to six percent
with the movie maybe even seven percent
nice yeah let's get those percentages
i wanted to ask you guys about maribel's
mother's gift because i thought it was
really beautiful how she heals through
food was there a meal
that you both ate growing up that gave
you life or healed you you know my mom
was bolivian and one of the things that
i didn't experience until actually
moving to l.a she has some family in la
and her family is bolivian in la and
there's this dish called tunyo which is
a potato dish from bolivia and like
it's like nothing i've ever had before
and also eating it i felt immediately
sort of like i know this
i know this dish which is your dna yeah
it's so cool sometimes how food can
really make you feel connected to
family that's long long past trails of
your dna that are gone gone gone and yet
you still feel like this feels just
right yeah it's amazing that the mom
heals with an arepa con queso because
you know mom's cooking is healing i mean
my mom makes a sancocho forget it i am
i'm healed uh every every problem i've
had anything with hollywood or a movie
doesn't do well
and boom i'm okay
that's my meal too what is it about
sancocho and it takes like a whole day
to make like a whole flight
but that's why because like somebody
that's gonna make something for you that
takes a whole day my mom complains to
the whole time though
i have to work so hard to make this for
you i hope you appreciate it of course
sure it's so true and if i got in a car
accident my mom would give me sancocho
before taking me to the hospital
before the intravenous we're going to
give you sankocho
i love you guys so much um stephanie let
me let's talk about sankojo because
that's reminding me of like in the
heights this is another film that you're
in with lin-manuel miranda's songwriting
what is it about his songwriting that
stands out to you it's incredible
he as a songwriter is so gifted so
talented such a genius and also such a
deep deep researcher he has such respect
for music of all kinds you know you can
hear it in the heights you can hear it
again in something like hamilton where
the respect for black culture hip-hop
culture rap is so deeply deeply threaded
into that musical and then with this
film with encanto it's this research
that he and other filmmakers did for
years and years really working on
researching colombia and the sounds of
colombia and making sure the music was
just right inviting actual colombian
musicians to be a part of this film so
that it sounds authentic authentic and
real and and lynn has such respect for
musicians and music and you can feel it
in the songwriting but also he's like
extremely creative in this like really
fascinating interesting way one of the
things that lin said about one of
mirabelle's songs is that the timing he
wanted to time it so that it was sort of
like a waltz because a waltz can feel
kind of out of time and mirabelle's
character feels out of step with the
rest of her family wow that's so cool i
mean like you don't only know that if
you're lynn i had already recorded the
song i didn't know any of that someone
was singing it you know you were feeling
it but i was feeling it i could feel
that it did feel slightly out of
tune with the rest of her family right
and like that's something that lin
manuel brings to
his writing is this like really
thoughtful
character analysis yeah he's really
brilliant he's really brilliant wow what
a beautiful answer thank you for that so
yeah there's so much intention behind it
that to the average person like you
wouldn't know and and how lucky to be
able you know to work with people like
that it's been a huge year for you
stephanie you know with brooklyn
nine-nine encanto in the heights you had
a baby congratulations thank you
is there anything that you did for the
first time as a performer this year that
you can share with us since the roles
have been so varied the thing that i did
for the first time was become a disney
heroine and
and at the same time i was like as i was
laying down sort of like
these songs and you know the the voice i
was also really cognizant of the fact
that i was pregnant and going to have a
kid that would possibly see this work
someday you know i think
everything else i've just been like i'm
just going to do what i want to do
because i'm going to be me
you know like but this is like i am
going to do me and i'm also like
conscious of the responsibility that i
think i
have not not like the type of story
necessarily because i want to tell all
types of stories but it's more like the
responsibility of like how do i make
this as authentic as i possibly can and
make it feel like something
that's real so that somebody else
connects to this in a way that feels
really real
yeah i'm not super strong like luisa the
donkeys got out again
or effortlessly perfect like senorita
perfect
felicidades on the film guys what a cool
project to be a part of all your
characters are so funny but there's so
many lessons to be pulled from each of
them
you know like diane and jessica your
characters are the brawn and the beauty
of the family yet they share a lot in
common i feel like they feel like they
have to live up to other people's
expectations so what message do you want
people to take from your character when
watching encanto be yourself yes you
know um just shout out to
uh robin williams in one of my favorite
movies aladdin
um be yourself
you know there's a lot yes aladdin
there's a lot of talk about this you
know authenticity and
being genuine and organic yet you know
yeah we're still sort of like following
a lot of like what's in this societal
construct you know what i mean we feel
often wrong
to
step outside of the roles that we've
been given or step outside of something
that we've been doing for a long time i
love that my character brings that sort
of like you know seemingly sort of
perfect ability to make these beautiful
flowers and to sort of keep everything
together
but how can we really grow
if we don't experiment if we don't try
different things if we don't get
different interests like i mean we're
not going to stay the same person
forever just because we have certain
abilities while we're young or if we
find something that we're really good at
doesn't mean that we're not
we don't contain multitudes and that we
should be trying out different things
and that we might become just different
than who we thought we were
you know so i love that exploration
wow walt whitman i contain multitudes i
love that my favorite quote jessica what
about your character because i related
to lisa a lot an important lesson that
luisa learned is to speak up it's okay
to ask for help because though she can
literally physically do everything
there's a lot going on inside of there
and it's okay to talk about that it's
okay to be vulnerable it's okay to
actually not
have all the fuel you need to go through
your day and to open up to your family
and friends and people that you know who
love you and will be there for you
regardless especially because of all the
things that you know you bring to them i
mean that aside
it's not that like the role that she
plays that's not all that defines her
she's she goes through the struggle of
realizing that and it's a beautiful
journey for her to experience it was a
beautiful journey for me to go through
she realizes at the end of the day uh
you know she's actually got more support
than she realizes and it's not all on
her and i think i have realized that for
myself throughout this process
wow what a beautiful lesson to gain from
your own character
i love this guys i love you guys so much
i wish i was in the room with you wilmer
your character agustin you know he's one
of the few family members that doesn't
have a gift and he bonds with his
daughter over this how do you how did
you play the father figure and stand out
in this extraordinary family i feel very
fortunate i had a great creative
collaboration with my directors and
really trying to find the nuances of
like what what it would be like to be in
a family where everyone has this very
special and i iconic gift you know and
what was your contribution and i think
humility you know humility to accept
what you're not and then celebrating
what you really are and that's something
that i think he really
naively and and in a very uh innocent
way just portrays so out loud and i
think he's hoping that this is what
connects him with his daughter isabel
right because that that is the moment
when we're he always wants to connect
with us like hey it's okay do not be
special you know like and and with
what's really uh silly but beautiful uh
and pure about that is that his full
intentions is just to be a good dad and
then no matter how special everything
tends to be that um his love for her is
the only special gift that he would need
i think that when he looks at his whole
family and and looks like his role in it
i think it's that ever evolving
conversation and who are we as parents
today and when i think about the ability
to give you know new parents like myself
because this is the first time of me
playing a dad while actually being a
father you know it's uh it's a really
beautiful uh image to say hey it's okay
to be the dad that you're gonna be
not the dad that is you know archetyped
for you you know in many ways and uh and
he's kind of the definition of that this
is i'm being a dad my way and i and he's
unapologetic about it but he's also
innocently pure about it too
well i love that you you have that
authenticity to bring to the character
and
thanks sorry sorry oh thank you
what do i got to do to get snaps around
about being ourselves jesus man i
brought my daughter into this too
what's funny about your character wilmer
is that he's very accident prone in a
way so like you were saying it's okay
you know to be that and i love that his
wife can heal through her cooking and
through her food what super powers would
you possess in your own respective
families and and what superpowers and
gifts do some of your family members
possess i think the
power
i think the power of um empathy
i think that like i
i really strive for that in um in my
family is to try to be as understanding
as i can you know i've always tried to
offer that and i think that i you know i
strive for that even as an actor
um to you know in this in this position
that this beautiful gift that we've been
given to tell stories and to
um represent many walks of life um yeah
i think that i represent that in my
family i think i
the ability to
understand multiple languages in my
family is very much a role that i play
everyone has got their own
patterns and mannerisms and i think
being the youngest in my fam i've been
able to observe it all and i have been
able to
dissect it and define it and realize
where people are coming from so i think
i am a uh
multi-lingual
baddie in my fam and i kind of tell
everyone like hey this is what kiki
means by that this is where mamma mia is
my bad that's what dm means by that come
on like that is a superpower
i think that's the superpower i know
that i have played for a while and uh
yeah even more so now
you talk about the powers and start
thinking about my mom because my mom
does have the power of making that
episode like bring you back to life you
know okay
or some culture when you're sick you
know like a pot of soup you know that
has everything from like pork chicken
beef you know potatoes everything you
could think of in one pot and pressure
cooked for about six hours and then you
eat it for four days straight
like my mom has the power of like you
know food that heals she she talks to
animals all the time and in the form of
yelling at them
i also think my mom literally has a
super hearing because she can hear what
you're saying in the other room just
mentioned okay she got it oh my mom has
all of them you know so i wonder what
did i actually inherited from this
um and you know i will say that um for
me um
is is to
to know that life will be as complicated
as you decide that it will be you know
and i think that's my strength and
understanding how to simplify what we
often will rewrite as a difficult vision
of what is ahead um so i i'm the ever
optimistic i live in the half fool i
love
the uplifting of one another and you
know i really i really care for that so
i i hope that that is power that i can
continue with you know speaking of my
daughter you know give to her that
things are going to be as hard as she
chooses them to be and that if she deals
with them from in bird's eye view and
you think about how big the world is and
no problem in front of you is going to
be too big to solve damn true
i just have to tell you guys i'm
dominican and i was talking to john
sancocho has been a theme today and we
were talking about how our parents
always complain it takes so long to make
my mom's like i slaved over this for
three days
[Music]
where do they get all that soup from it
it's like a mary poppins bag it's like
so much i know it's like how about all
this liquid it didn't start with all
this liquid what what about all the
things that are coming out of there i'm
like i didn't see you put that in there
right i know and then my mom wants to
put it more she's like you need more so
you need to put more rice in it more hot
sauce i'm like mom there's a milk oh no
do i yeah like where is the wine that's
why the water bill is so high
what about when they want to give you
sankocho when it's like a hundred
degrees outside oh yeah oh yeah and
you're like yeah this is so refreshing
it's hot as hell outside like why are
you giving me this one
am this morning but it's better when you
reheat it on the fifth day oh yeah yeah
yeah
greasy and delicious
even in our darkest moments
there's light
where you least expect it
one of the scenes that really stood out
to me was when abuela and some other
people are fleeing from danger and i
felt like so i feel like so many kids
and parents in this country share a
similar experience so charisse why use
that as one of the first images we see
in the film
you know it was uh a long development
process uh to sort of get to where we
got but you know as we were thinking
about being inspired by magical realism
and sort of
trying to figure out sort of the
foundation of where this family's magic
would have come from we're always trying
to think about how to like ground it in
human emotion and human need and sort of
make the magic spring from that
and as we talked to our colombian
consultants our experts they talked a
lot about the history of displacement
within the country and then i also sort
of as a writer brought in kind of my own
family's history my parents my
grandparents came here from cuba with my
mom
and uh
just sort of thinking about that um
[Music]
moment of desperation and need
and the magic springing from that moment
of abuela alma's love and all those
things came together and uh that's where
we got the beginning of our movie from i
love that i think that was very powerful
and as i'm dominican and i am from south
florida so um very very relatable and
and what a beautiful message you
mentioned magical realism byron i love
magical realism because i love disney
and magical realism because it reminds
us that there is magic inside of us
always why this genre to tell this story
well you know it's perfect i mean one of
the things that like we we started this
movie five years ago this week which is
crazy that these these movies take so
long but congratulations
thank you we're so tired
it's amazing so proud of everybody you
know it's like when uh we started and we
started with lynn because lynn and jared
had just come off of moana together so
three of us started talking we knew we
wanted to tell the story about an
extended family this idea of how well do
your families know you how well do you
know your families and lynn was very
keen to have it set in latin america
none of us knew where exactly it should
be at that point but it became very
clear to us over that next year that
colombia was the place to go not only
because it's a crossroads of culture and
food and family and diverse families
an amazing mix of music as well but also
because it's one of the main
birthplaces of magical realism and that
style of storytelling so
heavily influenced our take on this
movie even us being blessed enough to
find cherise like jared and i read
tons and tons of scripts and plays and
screenplays to find the perfect partner
for this film and we literally there's
no lie he and i came in after going
through piles of scripts with one script
in hand and it was chris's play feathers
and teeth which does this amazing job of
blending magical realism with this
amazing suburban take on and there was
something so perfect about her and when
she joined the team it all became
completely but i think because long
story short
magical realism inspires this magic
that's tied to emotion it's not
arbitrary it's not a gift from a fairy
godmother which is great if you can find
them but this is about magic like you
said that's a part of all about who we
are uh emotionally and how much heart we
bring to that magic of our families i
love that and i'm excited for people to
learn that magical realism is something
that is birthed and and really innate to
colombia which i think is so just so
perfectly interwoven um jared you know
you've been living with these weirdos
for a while
what i i mean the characters
no you guys are just absolutely a
pleasure to be in the presence of as
someone who has a massive family right
to see an extended family in a disney
animated feature film is huge right
typically we get to connect with one to
three different characters so what was
it like casting for this film and how
did you know that you wanted stephanie
beatrice in the lead role oh well i mean
yeah as you said we've never tried to
put an extended family on screen before
because it turns out it's really hard to
do i think that one of the things that
we were really excited about literally
from the beginning i think like five
years ago we said we want this to be
about an extended family we want to get
to know them we want them to feel like
complex and multifaceted characters and
so we really spent a lot of time
thinking through each character's
journey along the way of course then
like you're saying we have to we have to
find the right cast because we want
those characters to come to life in a
way i think for all of us that feels
like they separate from one another they
have their own uh little quirks about
them and they have to feel like um like
people from your own family um and so i
think as as we started meeting each
member of our our cast i think of course
the first person we cast was was
stephanie because we knew
that we needed to have mita bell be the
real anchor of our entire story she
interacts with every single member of
the family um and we have to watch her
journey is our story we don't it's not a
buddy comedy usually there's sort of
like a two-hander we knew that whoever
played her would have to be able to do
all things be super emotional and quirky
and sing like unbel not just like one
song but many songs a lot of different
styles i think the opening song is the
fastest song in disney history there's
so many words and she had to be able to
do that but when stephanie came in she
actually came in for a different part
because we actually knew her from
brooklyn nine-nine and we were thinking
oh maybe it would make sense for luisa
we were early on and then as soon as she
started talking we're like oh that's not
stephanie's personality oh she's mutable
and her her actual audition song was
you're welcome from moana and it was so
hilarious and such a weird choice and
then when she started we're like that's
minabel what are we doing here and so
she started doing the mirabella lights
we're like done we're super super done
and i think what she's brought to this
movie she's ad-libbed so much of what
you hear
not just the the comedy parts was the
really emotional parts between her and
abuela alma
i cannot imagine a better person and
then every member of the cast that's
coming after that really that's what you
see on screen is those people's
personalities we didn't ask someone to
not be themselves
and we're really really lucky to have
such a huge amazing and very different
cast obviously
some of the characters in this film have
some special gifts so wanted to know
what superpowers gifts do you guys
possess in each of your families and
what are some of the gifts that your
family members possess we'll start with
you cherise
um
well
i would say
my mom makes like
chicken soup that i can actually ward
off any kind of like
evil spirits or bacteria so i'm gonna
say my mom is julietta
is it sankocho by any chance no but it's
like her cuban chicken soup and it is
like it is a true miracle so i will say
that's my mom
um and uh huh
that's my magic power
you know who knows maybe i got a little
peppa in me a little bit of fire a
little bit of ice
you know
it's all inside
i love that jared what about you
oh
well i'd say i'll tell you what my kids
would say my superpower is which is
telling really bad jokes and having no
shame
the no shame part of that they will tell
you is my superpower because i won't
stop and now my kids also have no shame
and they're terrible jokes so it's a
it's a it's a generation of powers that
uh i've come from no shame uh if you
have a dad joke that you just like keep
top of mind i you know what i i probably
should i'd say that there there were
many uh um i'm not i can't even get into
it right now it'd be it'd be it would be
terrible you actually would see shame
because you're taping this and then my
kids would lord it over me so i will not
do that i will not be pushed into that
and then in my family um yeah i mean my
mother definitely heals through food but
i'd say that one of the real
inspirations of luisa early on was my
older sister who is an amazing athlete
she's also an artist and one of the
first conversations we had with our
family on this movie uh i found it that
like
in college that she actually really
wanted to stop doing gymnastics and
being an athlete she wanted to to be an
artist and that was a really tough uh
thing for her to figure out and even
within my family because she was so good
at it but to know that there was this
other thing that this other passion she
wanted to follow so i'd definitely say
louisa for my sister wow i love that
thank you for that what about you byron
nice i'm trying to think about my family
i have so many people well i'd say my
sister has this talent for no matter
what she tries no matter what weird
thing she tries she adopts something and
she becomes excellent at it like i'll
call her up and she's actually building
onto part of her house or she's learning
oil painting or like last week she was
making wine she and her husband were
making grapes and like squishing grapes
like what do you do but she that's what
she she puts her mind to it she
accomplishes it she's amazing and i
think for me i have i think
being in denial i think
that is something in the movie that i
kind of relate to i have a cheerful uh
demeanor gekko i think sometimes i need
to look closer at these things that are
affecting my life but i think that i
think in general i'm the optimist of the
family and stuff but i think there's
something about
these roles that we see in the family i
really do see a lot of all of our
families that we've talked about because
we've talked about them a lot over the
last five years we're sorry families but
we've
had a lot of kind of family therapy
sessions where it's been a huge
discovery but yeah i think that i love
you i love hearing even jared and
theresa's pics that's great
[Music]
[Music]
and that's why coffee's for grown-ups
[Music]
if you're impressed imagine how i feel
mom
[Music]
you